and we are
here we have everyone we have the live
stream we started and we are now
recording
so let's welcome
our first talk from carolina who will
talk
about how we test satellites to take
picture
at planet club so carolina this is your
turn
thanks a lot thank you very much for the
welcome and still i will start and share
my screen
and start with the presentation
yeah so thank you very much i am really
happy to be here
i joined joined planet last year
almost a year ago and of course because
of the pandemic i
have not been able to meet my colleagues
in person
but i was able to work force
with with a great company and uh
with a really great team so yeah here is
my email address in case you have some
questions or something you'd like to
ask further i'll be happy to answer them
okay so let's start uh as you might
probably heard from our ceo
uh will marshall's uh planet mission is
to
image the whole world every day making
change visible
accessible and actionable our mission
has remained the same
since 2010 when planet was founded
and we are working every day uh focus on
our mission
so now i'll let you know which
satellites we actually use to make
our mission achievable we currently
have two constellation of satellites the
planet the scope satellites and the
skysat satellites for the planet scope
we
have more than 180 satellites in orbit
and they are
taking the images that we consider
medium resolution
while the skysat constellation is
integrated by
21 satellites and they provide the high
resolution
resolution images but to have a better
understanding of the differences i'll
show you a video
so yeah we see the round the earth
the rotation but we can also see in this
uh
video our planet scope satellites flying
around the earth at
98 synchronous orbit and they are taking
a three meter resolution
the skysats constellation they are
capturing images that can reach 50
centimeter resolution because they fly
at lower orbit
but similar to the planet scope
satellites they also fly in a
98 synchronous orbit almost
all of them i have to emphasize that we
had
we launched a group of satellites for
the skysat
last year and they are flying at uh in
incline orbit as you can see in the
video
that has 53 degrees and
what's something you might not be able
to realize from this video is the size
so the planets planet scope satellites
are similar to a shoebox and the
skysats have a size similar to a washing
machine
so it's still very very small uh and in
this uh
part you can see also the is the planet
scope images we take images of broader
areas
while we disguise that's we focus on
smaller areas and
of course we have a higher resolution
okay so um before we reach to the point
of having such imaging capacity we've
learned from experience that the
traditional approach on on getting
images
uh it's it's has its challenge so
one challenge can be the limited
coverage of the earth or the low revisit
that we can have over in a specific
place we also have uh face some
challenges of inefficient access of the
products and maybe
having also products that are not useful
or satisfying
so now our current approach is to image
the entire world as i mentioned already
using our planet the scope constellation
planet
satellite sorry constellation
with daily imagery we chances to detect
anomalies
take action and capitalize on change are
highly possible
so now with the global coverage and the
frequent revisit
we also work on easy and efficient
access of the products
and one of the tools that allows us to
access our products is the tasking
dashboard which is the tool that i'll be
explaining later on
but what makes the planet stand out or
what drives value for
users we believe that is the combination
of the hey
high cuttings that we work based on the
user requirements the global coverage
that we can reach
due to our constellation the efficient
delivery
that we have uh for our products and the
open and
accessible and open platform that we
have developed for
our customers and
after having say in all of this what we
do is work on providing solutions to the
needs
that are now um coming more often
so the solutions that we offer are
categorized in
four groups planet monitoring
planet-based maps
planet tasking and planet analytic feats
in this presentation i will focus my
talk in planet tasking but if you want
to have more details about the other
solutions
we have detailed information in our
website so
feel free to check it
and from this point on i will also
focus on the tasking for the skysats
only
so i talk about the company
and the satellites but not about my job
so what is my
role as
a satellite tasking engineer i focus or
i mainly
work with other planning and monitoring
so what does it mean
and another another is a request of
having captures over a specific area of
interest so my team focuses on arranging
and managing the image acquisition of
the areas
of interest one example can be this area
where we
aim to get some features for example
land or water
but we can also get requests of having
images of very specific spots
once we ingest the order is how we
called
we also have to track and monitor the
order so
that we make sure that everything is
correct or
if not we are able to take action
and um do the range that might be needed
after we get the images of course they
need to
have a quality control process before
it's delivered to its end user
and the story that comes after the image
is delivered is so
broad as we can now see much
more features that we were able to see
before
and i'll show you a specific examples of
very nice images
so in general what we
we offer with the skysat is image at 50
centimeter resolution
we also offer monthly weekly daily or
sub daily collections
also transparent and automated access to
the imagery acquisition
and we also have archive data
what what are the main products that we
offer we have point collects and a strip
coll
collects as you can see on the slide the
point collects have a dimension of five
by five
kilometer while the strip collects can
um
have also five kilometer width but can
reach up to 100 kilometer
length but each collect is composed of
individual
scenes so we have three cameras on board
each satellite and this is the reason
what
why you see these three strips
and we are capturing overlapping scenes
and at the end
we build up uh one collect
and in this slide you can see our full
architecture so we believe that with
imagery and together with the insights
and the delivery
we can make sure that we achieve our
goals
and at the end this is just a summary of
what we are really working on
to have acquirable earth and this is the
work of
so many teams doing really really great
job
so now as i said i wanted to show you
some examples and i'll show you the 50
centimeter resolution imagery
which um yeah i have it here
our constellation of skysatz was
initially flying at 500 kilometer
but then they were lowered to 450
kilometer
so this image is showing the collect
that we got
uh before or after at
first place sorry with the 5500
kilometer
altitude and this is the
same image um having the
been obtained at 450 kilometer this is
an image of the museum of flight in
birmingham alabama
and if i can go back and forth
you can easily see how the planes are
well or better defined with this second
image
i have also another example maybe you
are familiar with this
place or you might visited madrid
also in the left we have the 500
kilometer
uh obtained image and on the right side
we have the 450 kilometer
and in the in the higher resolution
image we can see the
street lines um better defined as well
and finally we have an old terminal in
shandong china
and we can clearly see how
some features are now clearly visible
so i'll i will now
jump to the tasking dashboard so
let me go through the
correct page and i'll share the screen
again sorry
yeah so one of the tools that i
mentioned before we use
to task our satellites our skysats is
called the tasking dashboard
and i i will have the i will start with
the demo session
but before explaining just a bit of what
we have
after i do the demo part i think i am
sure you will
better understand so from the right side
we have
a table of all the orders that we have
already submitted
of course for testing purposes and
yeah some information just information
that is linked to each
specific case we also have some filters
that we have applied already based on
the status of the orders
uh to have a quick access afterwards
and we have a user menu that i will also
go through to a login in the tasking
dashboard we you will normally only use
credentials a username and then a
password and this tool is
used for teams internally in planet and
also for
customers externally so
the first thing i do is showing you how
we create an order and for that it's as
simple as just clicking on
create order icon
and we will have something like this so
we will need to provide
some parameters in order to create or
the order
as uh we wish or the customer wishes
um so i first start providing appeal
number
uh which is um user or contract unique
identifier number
and i will use the one
we have for testing purposes
and after we have provided appeal number
we can see that
we use we can select one of the products
that we offer
i will not be talking about express
tasking because this is a product we are
still on
uh is in progress and testing phase but
i can
explain you about the last three
products so for the order login product
we pro we let the customer
ingest an order and also see the imaging
opportunities that
he or the customer can have um
within the next seven days for this
order so at the end what we offer is
just
um a collec imaging window to make sure
that the
the capture the order over the area of
interest is going to be
collected we also have monitoring
tasking which we
as the name says we monitor one specific
aoi with a defined cadence a cadence
means daily
weekly as i mentioned monthly or sub
daily even
and over the same aui and finally the
flexible tasking is
just another that we ingest and we can
take
the image within a specific toi so it's
flexible
finally well yeah i can
choose one of them uh maybe the
to start with the flexible so i want to
change to the flexible
and yeah maybe of course something very
important from
right from the beginning is the name but
uh this is something we can just provide
at
any time so let me
provide today's date and this is going
to be for flex people yeah
so after i have provided the first
parameters
we now need to define the area of
interest in which we
choose point line or area
so i explained you already the point in
line but
in this case we can also uh provide an
area order
and which is uh very simple and i can
also show you
in a second example so if i need to
provide a coordinates i know by heart
the
coordinates of the place where i was
born
so i will directly jump to it yeah
and it's a very small town
but it has a very beautiful volcano so
yeah
i uh sorry i was too excited i
when i provided the coordinate as you
might have seen
um i was able to get
the point shape that i mentioned five by
five but i can also um shift
as uh the place where i where i
would like to have it capture so it's a
very nice feature we can move it uh
or play around and when it better fits
then
and when we are satisfied then it's fine
we can also see the details the
dimension the area
and then we also need to define the time
of interest so if i want to
start the collect from today and maybe i
would like to end by
the 20th of uh june
this is up to us and it can be
at least 14 days
uh after 14 days uh let me check
another one
let's say end of may
and for requirements we can choose
between image or
stereo collect an image is something
that
i think it's already clear but a
nesteria collect is a collect
that will it's something it's two images
collected two or three images collected
over the same area
and those um those products are mainly
used to have three-dimensional
visualization
so let's keep with the image um
type and then we also can define some
satellite elevation angles but this is
something we use by default
and we will keep as they are we can then
go to the next step review the order we
can see the aoi where it was placed and
the
information that we provided and if
everything is fine we can just confirm
this order
after we have confirmed the other the
order is directly sent to our scheduling
system
and it's going then to be part of the
images that we are supposed to be
obtained with our
satellites so let me go back to the
initial table
and here you can see clearly that our
order is already placed
the status is in progress because it
it's already
starting and we can see some of the
details that we already provided
initially
and uh with this um table uh we
also have some other details we can
display more columns
to be shown uh in the in the table of
content
uh very specific details that we have
for uh
cases or whenever the customer meets but
it's a very very uh user-friendly
we can also be able to export
the table uh work with it later on
but also we have the nice chance to see
the orders um
how they are geographically distributed
so when i um change from the list
to the word map we can clearly see
everything that was
listed now displayed where they were
tasked so i device them in into the
place that i know i
provided another it's it's going to show
where it was i've been um testing quite
a lot so you can see how many orders
i've been
providing over the same place so yeah
this is a very very nice
tool that we can use and if we want to
now reduce the
the view we if there is any
need to only see the orders that are
in progress i can also apply some
filters i have the option over here
i can add a filter i can choose for
example the status
and i can just click on in progress
and then we will get only four and if we
go to the map again
only the four in progress are going to
be shown
so this is really um useful
and the status of the orders
um uh differ of course based on the
situation
if we are able if we were able to get
one collect
uh within the the time of interest and
uh making sure of the specific
parameters that we provided then it's
going to be
considered to be fulfilled so let me
show you one example
we have a fulfill order here and
we are going to see the captures so one
once we click over one of our um orders
we are going to be also another
kind of window is going to show the
information of the order
again also like a summary of what we
have
provided from the beginning then we have
another tab the second tab is the
captures
so in this case we can see how many
captures were
clearly uh collected after it went to
through our quality control process and
we can also see the history of the order
we can see when this uh order was
ingested how
if the collection started already and
how the the all the collections uh
went on until the day it was fulfilled
and
it was uh set to success so i can also
choose one of the orders
and uh sorry the images i can click over
it
and yeah as we can see this is a very
nice
image that we collected and the
information provided here
we also provide a specific naming so you
can see some names are being very
specific
which is the satellite that we use to
capture this image the satellite name
and we together with the date and time
when this order was captured so we can
also
download the aor aoi json or copy the
aoi
from this tab and
we are also able to set some um
email email um delivery so if you
want to know or to get in or to be
informed of
how you order uh went on um directly to
your email address we have the email
setting
here option down in the menu user menu
and from these you can turn on or off
depending on how you wish to be notified
if your order was created or if your
order was expired
it means that it was it might have got
some collects but they were not good
enough or satisfying
or we were not fulfilling the
number of or captures that we expected
different reasons if it was fulfilled
so different options to be
defined as as you prefer
and i can also and i would like to
really quickly
uh show you uh how it works when we
uh json
geojson sorry file
oops um
now let's let's check uh monitoring
order
i will now use different name
and
i now want to provide a line
so if i know the coordinates of the
region
that's as i said i know
them by heart but
yeah we have a line we can also move the
line
as we need we can also
shift it or rotate it sorry we can
rotate it
or we can also uh change the dimensions
we can also modify the the initial
dimension
this is a very nice um
chance that we have and for the
monitoring orders we just need to
specify how often do we want to get
these captures or this
aoi to be captured on a daily weekly or
monthly basis
we can choose um every one two
days as we need and how many times we
wanted to have
i want to have a daily basis for 15 days
for example then i will see how this
is going to be a schedule from the 21st
of april until the 6th of may
so this option is also very nice to use
and i can also show you the area order
so let me go back to the flexible
tasking
which allows the area order and
here we can uh already provide the input
as a geojson
and i have it already oops sorry
wrong uh here
so yeah if we have the json file already
um created we can
afterwards edit there is uh the chance
to
move or also shift uh edit
vertices as much as we
prefer and the rest of the details it's
also clear we can also upload a file
so geo files mainly kml
shapefile um different options so now
it's uh
more open and
i i think it's really clear enough
and i can now quickly show you the order
locking
so for the or the locking i can again
try the point
okay i would like to move it and
now in this case the next step is going
to be to choose the imaging window
so as i mentioned the customer will be
able to see the imaging opportunities
after seven days from the day uh from
the starting date
so this is going to take just a while
and we can see the options if we want
this aoi
this area of interest to be captured on
the 14th of april at
the three for 14 pm then i can
choose confirm this window
and i can then review the order and one
once the order is
um everything is fine with the order i
can
go ahead and ingest it as well so
this is um very easy to use
and this is really making
our lives easier so yeah
i hope i fulfilled the expectations
but we still have uh five more minutes
for any question
or something you would like to know i
can go back to dislikes or
keep on this page but thank you very
much for the attention
thank you um so please
if you have any question write them
in the chat and we can
answer and we can forward them to the
carolina
the first one is always the hardest
okay i i actually have a
a question uh which is like right now
you have
so the the process is okay we have a
question from phil so that's
i'm the less interesting uh
so uh please tell a
phil is curious to know how much it
costs to monitor like for example
five kilometer square daily hi can you
give us a sense of the price that's uh
okay unfortunately i don't have those
details
um so i will if there is any uh
special needs please feel free to
contact me by email and we can then
reach the the team that it's related to
our sales and prices
that was just curiosity you just say
that
yeah yeah great makes sense yeah also
recurs
to know um but um
i suppose this really depends on the
clients and things like that so what i
wanted to ask is actually you are
you have like some some orders basically
um
but it can really depend on the weather
right i mean like for example in berlin
if i we asked something today
then we could not get a clear image so
how do you make sure that will work or
like
or how do you account for that basically
yeah this is a great question and for
sure we have optical
images or opt we are taking optical
images
which is the drop back the weather
conditions and this is not happening
with uh
i i know if you have heard rather
satellites so
the cloud condition is not a problem but
yeah we
this is the reason why we are able to do
some attempts
so if something is not uh in favor of
mainly the weather
we for flexible tasking specifically
depends on the product
but for flexible tasking if it is really
not a possibility it was
really cloudy we are keep on tasking so
might be that within the time of
interest everything was not that good
um but we also try to
make sure that we do the quality control
as we
uh really um expect the customer to be
satisfied
sometimes we get a cloud a specific
percentage of clouds which is fine for
the customer
so we have to deal on a
scene or collect basis more than scene
collect basis
and we see how the scenes are but really
checking or cross checking with the with
the captures that we get
yeah makes sense thanks
we get a question from manuel um
[Music]
who are your biggest client of your
services products
if you are what's i mean i don't know
how much you are allowed to disclose but
who is using your service basically yeah
so um i would like to have a
to provide an overview of the usages
more than
customer names we are providing products
or
collects for universities for example
so they are doing research projects and
they would like to have
clear images of the earth i personally i
had a nice experience i was
able to work not with satellite planets
and
images but with sentinel which are free
to be able to get the displacement of
the earth after an earthquake
so this is very interesting to be used
in the
scientific community we also deliver
products to
a newspaper maybe you knew that we had a
crisis in the
swiss channel so we were able to take
images of the
this big tank or
i i forgot the name but this was a
really
um huge tank being blocking it so
this was really um useful as well
uh and there are specific
clients customers that would like to use
this to assess changes
uh over the time because as i mentioned
we also have archive data
so we can have data from before
analyze changes mainly environmental
changes as well
so the usage is really broad
thank you hope that answer your question
um i'll also get some a question from
youtube
um i'm not sure if it's uh if there are
anything like that but
can you use that to implement in our
apps i mean is there any kind of
thing that could is there an app or a
way to
show that in an app on a way or like
you just get the image and then you do
whatever you want with it
and we have another an external app uh
which is called planner explorer and
this app it's
um i i will say very similar to
google earth more or less so we can see
the collects uh
in the base map it's uh very nice to see
the naming of the streets and so on so
it's much more detailed and we have this
as an external tool as well related to
the tasking dashboard the tasking
dashboard is really a specific for
customers and the internal users
as i mentioned while planet explorer
being one of our apps
you can access for 14 day free trial
and you can have a look of how it works
as well
cool thanks we also get a question
um can you tell us more about the
scheduling of order
to how so how does the scheduling of
other two satellites happen
so yeah so then
after we ingest the order as i mentioned
we have
a scheduling system um that it's
compiling
every all the orders that we um provided
at the end
and this information is going to reach
the satellite once the satellite is
crossing over our antennas so there are
communication antennas placed over
a specific regions of the earth and once
the satellite's flying over those
antennas then we are able to sense the
information
and the satellite itself which will uh
also collect
and everything the afterwards will
happen we are providing the detail as
deep as
much detail as we uh know as you see how
we
need to provide and afterwards we are
waiting for the collect to be obtained
so if i can
choose this the one uh i can choose the
second one i
i ingest it here and then
so we can see from the history that i
submitted the order the collection has
started nothing yet has happened
afterwards but if we go
to uh let me check one which is already
fulfilled
sorry let's see the history
so it's the uh we have the collection
has been scheduled we each at the
specific
time and once that
light is we know it's going to pass over
this region then the capture was
obtained it's downlinked and then it's
going to be processed
once the capture is processed then it's
going to be published and when it's
published it has to be manually assessed
unfortunately invalid
but if we get another one
still the same process goes on
until we have it as a success
more or less this is what i can describe
i hope it was clear
answer the question
yeah sounds that's
i mean it's i suppose there is a really
big logic
behind of how you define which satellite
should do which
thing and how when on which
thing it should transmit the data and
everything but
not something that you can explain in
five minutes yeah
it's quite a process
um also also we also get some question
uh
so why did you decide to put the
satellites in
the 450 450 500
kilometers and more and not or closer to
earth
in order to provide an even better
resolution
okay so not being really satellite
expert i know there are some
problems that will not allow the
satellite light it's such lower
altitude so the 450 was
possible because the satellites have
propulsion
and they were able to be lowered but
reaching very low orbits i think it's a
real real
real challenge for the satellite to be
appropriately working
atmosphere probably yeah yeah
exactly it's getting too thick so that
it's slowing down the satellite
um
uh oh yeah also some question a number
question
if you know uh let's shoot uh what's the
data exchange
rate between the base station and the
antenna uh the base station antennas and
the satellites
so do you know by any chance
the rate how much is able to be
transmitted
oh no this is a good question uh i
really don't know how much data it
really is
um but i i i think it really depends
i don't know the maximum or minimum
values but uh it depends on
um where antenna is located
uh how much information by this antenna
was gathered
and how many orders we have been placing
or
ingesting so it's i think a number that
it's
very much changing but i really don't
know how much
can be
great thank you
yes actually and i also had
or the same question uh which is uh is
python
used in this context so in all what you
are seeing probably
uh in the back end if there's some is
there any python involved
and i am pretty sure yes i am pretty
sure and
yes it wild yeah
at least widely used basically python
except the frontend of course yeah is it
the main
backend language yeah
yes
python in space really cool
i mean not in space but to
to to make things happen in space
i was looking for them yeah sorry
great uh any other questions please
shoot or otherwise
i will say i'll just
let it open one more minute uh
any question please please
let me just check
yeah that will be it so thank you
thank you again uh carolina uh it was
really
nice to see this
product developed by planet lab
if you have any question that popups
afterwards you can always
ask them uh afterwards i will have
another
meeting using wonder where you will be
able to have a kind of
more uh pi data
physical meeting setup where you'll be
able to move around and
see other people will share about the
shadow league at the end
so if you want to have some if you have
more questions
so now thanks a lot
i will be thank you very much um
so what i propose now uh is to have
a few minutes break um
so i propose to start again at eight so
if you want to grab a beer uh you have a
pizza
this is kind of the theme of meetups
usually so
feel free to go stay here we can have a
chat
if you want also
and after that we will welcome the
second talk
you
so
great
we will start soon
and that we need our speaker yes he's
here
i was afraid don't leave us now
now ready to roll ready to roll okay
a little great scary ah
we we got enough pump on the road please
um from now on yes
i so welcome for the second
break i hope everyone has some beer and
some pizza or
any non-alcoholic beverage that seems
fit
for the time being uh and let's go to
our second talk
uh with biotech
who will talk about how to detect silent
failure
in ml models so
this is your stage
all right thanks a lot for the intro and
without further ado let's delve into it
uh if you could tell me that you can see
my screen
yes we can cool perfect um
so what i'm going to talk about today is
how to detect cell and failure
but before we delve into that let me do
a quick intro
so i'm voidtech one of the co-founders
of 9ml we are a very small
vc funded startup that deals with ai
monitoring
what we try to do is basically answer
the question that's asked here
we're trying to detect silent machine
learning failure
and then address it in some way which
seems to be quite relevant to basically
almost every data scientist that right
now
works in models that make it to
production because models tend to
fail a bit and why do i have something
to say about it that
might be interesting so i used to run a
machine learning consultancy
and we did end-to-end projects and then
at the end clients were always asking us
okay now what
uh how to make sure that this thing
still keeps on working
and we didn't really have an answer for
that so we started
kind of investigating uh what happens
with machine learning after it has been
deployed and if it fails
uh what can we do about it um
also just before we delve into it uh let
me say
we are hiring so if you'd like to work
in a
very cool nice remote uh high growth
startup
uh working on core product working on
basically machine learning for machine
learning
and you're most welcome to apply i'll do
a bit of
i'll talk about it a bit more later on
so let's talk about how to detect
silent machine learning failures in
production so what's on the play today
first we'll just do a quick definition
of what is model failure
then well so basically just yeah what it
is
then we'll explain what happens when the
models fail what are the consequences of
model failure and why
this is an important thing to tackle
both from technical and business
standpoint
uh then i will talk about the causes the
reasons why machine learning can fail
and probably will fail in production
uh we're gonna follow up with detecting
machine learning failure so really the
tool set for that the machine learning
monitoring part
and then we're gonna have a very quick
engineering slide
about how to incorporate machine
learning monitoring toolset
either one you build or one that you
decide to purchase
into your infrastructure so
let's start with
a running example that i'll be using
throughout the presentation
to make the the machine learning
monitoring a bit more real a bit more
grounded
so imagine that you're a data scientist
at the big bang having 30 million
clients
and the biggest product line is
long-term
loans maybe mortgage loans and
working on the core machine learning
model
that basically does create default
predictions so we take the credit scores
and the customer information and based
on that we try to predict whether
somebody's gonna default or not uh so
and that way we can approve or
disapprove a loan
uh we're gonna define the
loan default as non-payment over one
year so it's not known immediately we
need to wait one year to release whether
this person is going to default or not
uh we need to optimize our kind some
kind of business metric
let's pick something that's typical in
in fintech in banking so we try to
just predict uh optimize for roi return
investment and we're going to adjust it
by some risk factor so the more risky
loans
uh will have lower roi even though
expected roi may be higher and
of course when we have a business metric
we want to approximate to using some
kind of technical metric
uh the one that's widely used everywhere
in data science would be on a beta score
and in case you forgot what it is here's
just a very quick
um very quick overview
and an er equation basically what it
does is we try to weigh the true
positives and true negatives in a way
that
really reflects the business problem so
let's say that people that
apply for a lot and then default are
more problematic that people
who would not have defaulted but we
still reject them
so we need to wait in some way
so imagine now we have this uh model
this mold is bringing
few billion a year but if the quality of
the model decreases by even a few
percentage point
we go from making billions to actually
losing billions and the company might go
bankrupt
this is actually not an exaggeration
that's how that's how
loan applications work on big scale and
if you systematically
underestimate the risk uh the bank might
go bankrupt this is exactly what
happened in
2008 so we have our example
now let's talk about machine learning
failure
so machine learning failing
characterized by three things silent one
first of all everything looks okay the
machine learning system still
outputs predictions it's not an obvious
failure you've seen no errors
predictions are made if you look at them
and if you have a business person look
at them
look at 1500 200 examples they will all
look reasonable
the loans that should be rejected will
be rejected the ones that are kind of on
diverge will be on the verge
and everything looks fine at first
glance and second glance
and you don't really know whether
performance is good or not because you
will see
using our example only the real label or
real ground truth
a year from now but if model fails the
performance will have degraded
significantly
which is of course a big problem so
why is it a big problem let's talk about
the consequences first of all
in basically best case scenario you will
see a decrease significant decrease in
roi
because maybe you're pricing your loans
uh too high you're
maybe rejecting too many people and
that's still
kind of good failure because you're just
losing money a bit of money
but it might get worse in a sense that
you're not only not making any money
with your machine learning model which
is
in the end the goal of all machine
learning models or
almost all machine learning models but
also you might start losing money
you will have unforeseen and hidden
risks here
using our example again you can have
systemic risk if
model for some reason always approves
some loans that shouldn't have been
approved and it does it in systematic
way uh the company is almost guaranteed
to go bankrupt
when these people start defaulting few
years down the line all at once in very
correlated fashion
and that's not that's not it that's not
the end of it
we can also have problems with the
downstream failures
so imagine that marketing and customer
acquisition department
also tries to get the clients that
give the highest roi and the highest roi
at first glance would be the people
that uh you approved for risky loans but
if this risk
is not taken fully into account your
marketing and customer acquisition
channels will go for the people that
should not be given the loans at all and
it will only make the problem
worse and worse so the consequences can
be serious but now
let's look at the the reasons behind it
before we
start talking about the solutions so the
basic reason is really really trivial
your models are trained on static data
normally unless you use
uh online learning which is right now
still very rare in business
so you train the model on training data
set
you test it you validate it blah blah
blah it works good
ready to be deployed you deployed but as
time passes the environment changes so
the input data and the patterns between
the inputs and the outputs of course
will also change
and that means that your model is no
longer a good representation of the
reality
so it will stop working and fail
silently
here to have a very specific example
let's assume that the model has been
trained on all population
but now more and more young people apply
because maybe the bank created new
really nice sleek web app
or mobile app and people actually start
using this bike
and young people tend to be more risk
prone but the model didn't know that we
didn't model it
because there was just nothing like
young people to take that into account
so machine learning model will
systematically underestimate risk and
that
is uh basically a risk for disaster
this is the kind of basic failure mode
that is the main
kind of idea why models fail in
production because things change
now let's look at the less obvious
things
one of them is that every machine
learning model as it interacts with the
environment as it interacts with the
population
actually also affects the population and
the population will affect the data that
the model ingests
imagine here that the customers
consciously change
what they actually say in their law
application what things they hide
because the model needs to be fully
can be fully explained as this is the
regulatory
regulatory necessity so customers will
start uh trying to fool the machine
learning system
and in time they will succeed which
might decrease the performance of the
model another thing
kind of obvious is that we can have
stochastic shark sphinx just coming from
the outside that change how
customers behave how long application
process looks like
you can have a new regulation that
imposes lower down payments so people
are more encouraged to take loans and
the system was not trained on that
population our model is not used to that
so it will not take it into account and
the last thing is that invention we
expand from
even from berlin to bavaria
will have kind of different population
there are different risk profiles people
will behave slightly differently
and the model again is not used to that
and then let's talk about last two
reasons one of them is
very long cycles that we haven't
captured in our data
one example here would be the boost and
the boom and bust cycle
which can span 20 30 40 years even
and if we take 5-10 years which is
normal
to use the data from five to ten years
from now
we will not be able to capture the
cyclical nature
and as we enter new phase in the cycle
the model will not be able to
really capture the patterns that happen
during this part of the cycle and the
last thing kind of obviously
is that as our data become more noisy
because maybe there's new bugs in the
credit scoring system
uh we'll lose performance but that's
kind of a given
so we have the reasons we know what we
know what happens we know the
consequences and we know the reasons
now let's re-talk about the most
important thing here which is the tool
set
of how to actually detect it so
detection of machinery
of machine learning failure is hard
because you
it's silent right and there are some
ways to try to
approximate it try to find the potential
secondary causes
of machine learning failure or secondary
symptoms
and one of them is data drift data drift
is basically
change in the data input so not the data
outputs not
what we try to predict but just changing
the distribution of data inputs
uh if we look at 2d example that i've
shown here and we see that
the um the data points were kind of
clustered together
and still the module managed to find a
very nice decision boundary between them
but as time passes maybe they will
really become bi-model
and right now you would see that the
decision boundary the second image
doesn't really reflect how the model
would
create it again if it was retrained on
the new data
and it's easy to spot it it's easy to do
it manually to make sure that there is a
problem
but what if you need to work with
hundreds or even thousands of features
then
of course this is not possible to just
model it like that and look at it
visually to see if there's change in the
in the data distribution so we need some
kind of algorithmic and statistical
tools to detect that
and as the data changes it might be that
right now the model is making
predictions on
new regions in the data that it was not
trained on so would not capture the
patterns there
which might of course cause failure so
first and simplest way to solve it is
just diffuse that this univariate
statistical test something like called
monograph smearing of tests
or our chi-square test our exact fisher
test when we look at every single
feature separately
we look at the distribution previously
either during training or maybe last
month
last week last day and compare it to the
current distribution
and if it is statistically different it
means that we do have data drift
and this data truth might be kind of a
symptom
of incoming model failure
if we want to look at it not from the
perspective of just one variable at a
time but we want to look at them
at the same time a very nice way to do
it is to just run another model
detection we fit our anomaly detection
algorithm something like
one class svm or isolation forest we
run it on the data where we do have the
labels and we know
uh what is the performance and then as
the time passes we will just see
whether there's more and more anomalies
coming and if we see more anomalies in
our current dataset compared to the
previous data set
it's a strong indication that data drift
is
happening and again that might cause
problems and the last
most advanced way to detect data drift
is using generative adversarial neural
networks
when we train the gun on our training
data
so it learns how to pirate how to mimic
the training data
and then we use the discriminate
discriminator part of the network
in order to basically see if the new
production data
is significantly different from the
training data that way we can really
capture all characteristics of the data
set
using a neural network it's the most
advanced way and should be the most
robust and most efficient
but of course guns are very hard to
train and
they tend to get stuck in local minima
so it's easier said than done
uh
now uh i'm gonna walk you through a mini
example of how to do it
um just when you can you know tomorrow
start working again and if you're
curious about whether there is actually
data drift currently in in my model um
what you can do
is you import one of the uh statistical
tests i mentioned
you could uh for example import comm
call mo
gara smirnoff test to work on
continuous data you take one feature
that you're interested in
you set the default key value to 0.05
you run the test compare for a given
feature
comparing the previous month and
distribution of the current month
distribution
and if the return the result of the test
is that
the distributions are different with
p-value below 0.05 percent
it means that the feature has drifted
very simple thing
uh but just something for you to try out
later on
if you want to work with um categorical
uh features then you need to use chi
square test
for binary categorical features you
should normally go for the
fischer's exact test these are just
names they
work in a reasonably similar way to give
you a quick overview of how the
ks test works it takes two distributions
it looks at the cumulative distribution
and then it basically computes the
area between those two and if it's
sufficiently big it tells you that there
is drift in the data
so now let's move on to the second way
of trying to detect whether the model
has failed
and this is the concept drift concept
drift can quickly be defined
as change in the decision boundary so
again we have a 2d
example here and on the training data
our decision boundary has been
determined or maybe it was real like
that
and now if we had looked at the labels
we would actually see that the label the
decision boundary looks like this so
it's
completely different but the patterns
are different the model doesn't work
anymore
and that of course strongly implies that
your model has failed
and your um your predictions won't be as
good as they used to be
uh how do we try to really detect
concept
this is hard in itself and if we have
access to labels we can do a few
simple things first one would be just to
do the correlation analysis between
inputs and the labels not the outputs
but the labels themselves
and if we see that the correlations
themselves are drifting
then it means that we have concept group
because the
the pattern between the inputs and the
outputs
has changed then another thing what we
can do a bit more advanced than just
correlations we can create a model
your normal xg boost let's say fit it on
the training data
then fit it again from scratch on last
month
last week last day and then see if the
model parameters are significantly
different if they are
again we're just right now trying to see
the mapping
between the pattern between the inputs
the outputs has changed if it had
then we have console proof and that is
all nice but we don't really need it
that much if we have access to leverage
because then we can just measure
performance
so what can we do if there's no labels
so we don't have the ground truth
the actuals and
one thing we can do is we can measure
the drift in
current feature importance imagine we
have our hd boost model
and the model has certain future
importance maybe the most important
thing is the credit history
then is the current income and then
maybe location
we take that and we look at the future
importance for every
single example and then sum together
using something like shot values
and the training and then compare it in
production
it might be that because of the data
drift actually the
the features that tend to be important
for every single example in the
production will be slightly different
than the one
in the training and if we all sum them
up together and average
average them and the future importance
is going to be different and that
kind of implies that there's still
concept drift on top of just data drift
now moving on to the last part
of detecting machine learning failure
here we try to
directly measure performance or at least
estimate it
and the easy thing we can do is to just
measure
and do statistics on the metrics on
things like f beta scores f1 scores
precisions rmses etc
if they change then of course our model
is failing as simple as that
and again things get interesting if the
labels are delayed or not available at
all imagine that you're doing
a document classification you will never
really have access to labels because the
machine is doing the job that the person
was supposed to do
so right now you will never see the true
label unless you actually have
a human do the same work all over again
which defeats the purpose of
of using machine learning in the first
place so what we can do then
is instead of trying to see whether the
model is correct or not
on every single label which basically is
recreating the model
you can look at the aggregate
performance
which funnily enough is easier to do
just looking at every single example
i will not go into details now but happy
to answer questions later
uh why is that but we can estimate the
other
the aggregate performance using things
like data drift concept drift the
features itself statistics
put that all in the model and another
machine learning mode built on top of
our current machine learning use case
that takes the input data from the past
as inputs for machine learning inputs
and outputs
from the past as inputs to the model and
then as outputs
we have the aggregate performance of the
model again
from the past on our historical data
and we built this model we fit it and
then we can
estimate the performance on current data
set when we don't have the labels
it is not guaranteed to work our current
version is just a prototype
it seems to be quite robust but of
course it's it's an open question and
by some definitions it's impossible to
fully solve
and then the last thing again something
easier is to do statistics on
business kpis if we have access to
direct business kpis
uh then of course we can just look at
them and see how they change
maybe it would be the volume of
applications etc etc
and if it goes down then it's a problem
so that was how to solve it from kind of
algorithmic perspective
now let's look at the architecture uh
the engineering perspective of that
what i have here is a very simple
radically simplified
uh kind of diagram
of how a typical machine learning system
looks like
so on the left here we have a business
process
uh which emits some kind of data
that is taken as a model input so your
typical features right credit score
credit history income location
uh occupation things like that for
example with our running example of
uh credit scoring uh so this is the
model input
then we have a machine learning model
that doesn't magic and then it outputs
model output obviously what we need to
do is we take those two
then you take it into your machine
learning model with the
sorry machine learning monitoring system
whatever it is
we take those two things you compute
data drifty compute concept truth we try
to estimate performance
and if we have also access to the
database with downstream data
things like business kps things like
labels or ground truth so whether the
model has failed
sorry whether the um credits
was successful based on has paid back
the credit or not
and maybe some other data if we can get
access to that we should also take it
into account
and the last thing if we do have access
to model itself
it will also allow us to directly see
what are the assumptions that the model
has
whether for example it's strict linear
model then if there's some new
non-linear relationship in the data we
know for a fact we don't need to check
it that the model is not capturing that
so there is a problem
if we don't have direct access to the
model we can still create a surrogate or
fake or shadow model which should
quite well approximate the machine
learning model that's there
but maybe the assumptions won't really
be the same then we take it into our
machine learning system
uh where we compute all these things and
then we can output it in a dashboard as
notebook instance
uh just as an api so that the downstream
service is something like maybe
training framework uh can take it
and act on the alerts if there's an
alert that the model performance is not
good and the reason for that is that the
data has drifted
maybe just retraining will fix it so we
take that
and then we use it later on
uh so that's basically it uh what i
wanted to share before we finish
is just few resources uh there is a kind
of
ish library called psychic multiflow
developed by
guys from the data streaming community
it only works with data streaming so
it's not
it will not work out of the box on most
machine learning use cases
but nice thing about it is that they do
have a lot of drug detection algorithms
they're a bit more advanced with simple
statistics so yeah you're welcome to
give it a try
uh a few of our competitors i'm just
gonna go with the biggest ones
fiddler ai they're based in silicon
valley arterial based in new york
enterprise stuff and then when it comes
to interesting things
a bit more self-promotion i have a blog
on how to get started monitoring
give it the read if you like it and then
a few papers kind of seminal papers
about how to do juke detection uh
basically these two guys are the biggest
names when it comes to
data drift detection uh gia games
portuguese
uh albert bife is from paris i think
so give it a go uh you'll see this
presentation later you can just click on
the links you don't have to like take
screenshots but you're welcome to
and last thing more self-promotion is
yeah we're looking to hire data
scientists and also data engineers but
mostly data scientists currently
so come work with us we are super cool
people very small startups for people
we are vc funded so we're not gonna run
out of money anytime soon
and we offer good salary we offer stock
options we are fully remote
i live in portugal uh one of my
co-founders right now
is in spain another in belgium uh
and yeah we're cool people join us
uh also feel free to you know add me on
linkedin
send me an email or anything like that
also
if you need uh you know machine learning
monitoring also
uh let me know and that's it thanks a
lot
great thank you very much
thank you nani sorry
so questions yes actually
we have one in the chat um
okay so let me read it how far does the
noise in the
data and the overfitting of the model
influence side and fader of the models
so influence is what influences uh
influence a silent fader of the models
so i would say that the more noisy the
data is the more robust the models will
be
surprisingly because uh robustness
basically
regularizes the model they will be much
less performant because you have noise
in the data
but that also means that they will
whatever performance they have will
generalize quite well so they will be
more robust
and the models that are really really
optimized as much as possible
and the more they overfeed the more
overfit they are the
more you are likely to experience silent
failure if something is really over
fit or is not strictly speaking over fit
compared to the validation set but
overfit
compared to reality once you deploy it
you actually see that the data is
slightly different than in production
slightly different than what you trained
it on and the money is gonna fail
so here you should also take into
account that
even injecting some noise would make
your model more robust
interesting
can i jump in with a question yes please
hey so just one question how
much of the cost of this uh right now
like
how how would you estimate the cost
multiplier
of a deploying and monitoring in
production
compared to of developing the system in
the first place
that's a good question i would say it's
more or less negligible compared to
development when it comes to deployment
maybe around 10 we honestly did few
calculations when you're raising money
how expensive monitoring is going to be
in the future and we
ended up at around 10 of the the general
op system operations
so not really compared to development
but compared to deployment and
operations
you should add around 10 to make sure
it's monitored well
and everything goes fine which i think
should generate
decent roi given that if it fails it
will not only
wipe out all the value it has provided
but take a big chunk more on top of that
thank you
another question
um i have a question then if the ones um
so what are you focusing or
at some point you talked in one of the
slides that you said like you have a
bigger model which take the the model
input the model that input the data set
and train another model on top to be
able to predict the aggregated
statistic of it
is it what you are focusing on in any ml
is it
uh or is it yeah
yeah it's actually one of the the core
things that we are working on right now
because people really want to know
what happens if we don't have the labels
how can we still estimate performance
and they see it as complete witchcraft
so that is something that we're trying
to solve because it's first of all
it seems to be needed basically everyone
speak with says like yeah if you can
solve it yeah we want it
and also it's very interesting to work
on because it's a very hard
technical problem that has not been
resolved
yeah so that's very much is our focus
how do you do you see the product
i mean will that be open so like
do you have a kind of idea of how you
want to
develop it so base maybe i was a bit too
too humble when it comes to our state we
actually have a working mvp
uh so it's ready to be deployed it's
right now it's not
open source because the code behind it
is kind of ugly
but it works it's there and
we're ready to like we're rolling out
already we're working with companies
and monitoring their models doing first
pilots so it's their early stage but not
that early we are past the concept stage
and by default this is enterprise sales
because companies are normally very wary
to give their data away
even to a you know pure product
so they prefer to keep their data inside
their cloud
and for this reason we always need to
implement an email inside their cloud
so it takes some integration some manual
work
but in the future of course we plan to
release some open source components
looking forward to that
do we have another question oh yes we
have some questions
[Music]
um
okay our question from phil if you are
working with big data don't you find
that your
significant tests show up as significant
even from the tiniest drift
that will not matter in practice
uh yeah so it's all about tuning uh
interesting thing is of course if you do
it in a very naive way when you just run
a million tests some of them are of
course
tend to be positive so you need to take
that into account and you adjust your p
values even if you work with simple
statistics
um and when it comes to big data yeah
that's that's all about fine tuning we
want to
have as little false positives as
possible but of course still detect all
that
all the cases of failure and it's a hard
problem
uh but it's it's kind of a trade-off
between false positives and false
negatives
uh so we don't because we take that into
account but if you approach in a very
naive way you would indeed get alerts
all the time
make sense uh
question from namo what kind of clients
are you serving at the moment
yeah so we work right now we're
switching mostly to work with
fast-growing startups
but we also have two
uh two enterprise clients that we're
working with uh mostly fintech but also
one media company
uh that we're working with either big
enterprises or startups
the reason for that is startups are very
easy to work with and they have very
interesting problems and we can also get
kind of you know validation that the
problem is real
and enterprises are very interesting
just to see how we can potentially
deploy it and enterprise because this is
not an easy thing to do
also another question from demo uh do
you look at fairness of the models
not sure if you can yeah uh
we can possibly it's on our roadmap we
want to start with bias first instead of
going you know
just simple bias detection and data
especially change in bias if there was
somebody that was taken into account
and now new type of bias appears in the
data because maybe you know
marketing targets mostly males or mostly
old people
and there's new kind of bias in your
population
you will be able to actually detect it
automatically right now just looking at
the future distribution that it changes
and on our roadmap is to address it
specifically but
it's not there yet
great
thank you do we get some other questions
at the moment please feel free to ask
that's the time
where okay where are
so you have you are in portugal one is
in spain
where are the two others in belgium so
our we are legally incorporated in
belgium
uh but yeah we are fully remote as long
as you are free to travel
here within the european union it's all
good
great so if no other question i propose
to
stop here so thank you again a really
interesting presentation
and i will stop the uh the recording
uh we don't need it anymore
and i will also invite the people who
wants
to join us in wonder so as i said before
uh it's a kind of you can see of a 2d
plot
like a map where you will be a small dot
on the on the map and you will be able
to
move around and get close to other
people
and then at this point you will be able
to start the conversation so if you want
to have some questions directly with
the people so white tech
uh carolina if you if you are joining
also are you joining
yeah i'm joining great so if you want to
have some more questions about the the
company etc
feel free and carry now so if you are
might have some other question so i will
uh i will post it in the pi data meetup
uh in the comments and i will also post
it
in uh in the chat
so if you have any questions here
you can post it here and you get get it
here
and if you are in the
zoom in the in youtube can i also put it
in youtube
up we also have it in youtube great
so that's it thank you very much for the
one
thank you for the two speakers thank you
for the the audience
um we'll stop here
this part but you are welcome to join
in wonder the name of the company is so
great
okay see you see you soon i hope
otherwise see you around